a good afternoon I'm Matthew Spalding
associate vice president in Dean for
Hillsdale College here in Washington DC
welcome to Kirby Center for
Constitutional studies and citizenship
it was over 25 years ago that Allan
bloom wrote a book called closing of the
American mind which criticized higher
education for having failed at democracy
and impoverishing the souls of today's
students he pointed out the paradox that
the openness of relativism the dominant
philosophy of modern academy and
liberalism leaves interesting lis to a
closing too many of the greatest ideas
in books of liberal education years
after that and since we have seen this
closing lead to an increasingly closed
mindedness increasingly which is
increasingly militant especially on the
campus and that has come to threaten
free speech and academic freedom
fortunately at Hillsdale College things
were a little different
the only trigger warnings we have is in
our campus gun range
but our speaker today is going to
explain that and someone who has not
only written about this subject but
experienced it firsthand and we're very
welcome very happy to have her here with
us one of our students in this case a
recent graduate of Phil's OU college
will be introducing today Jenna Adamson
she's the class of 2015 a French and
English major
she's the WIPP program which is the
Washington Hillsdale internship program
the spring of 2014 and she's currently
working at national affairs dinner thank
you doctor
christina hoff sommers earned her BA at
NYU and her PhD in philosophy at
Brandeis University from 1980 to 1999
she was a philosophy professor at Clark
University in Massachusetts and from
1987 to 88 she spent a year as a
visiting lecturer with the University of
Pittsburgh semester at sea program dr.
summers is currently a resident scholar
at the American Enterprise Institute
where she is best known for her critique
of late 20th century feminism she is the
author of several books including who
stole feminism the war against boys and
freedom feminism it's surprising history
and why it matters today please join me
in welcoming dr. christina hoff sommers
thank you
freedom is not an abstraction it is real
and it affects our happiness our ability
to flourish to lead fulfilling lives and
it cannot be taken for granted it has to
be learned and it has to be earned even
fought for in every generation each
generation faces new temptations to
trade personal freedoms for promised
benefits benefits are abstractions and
usually abstractions that turn out to be
passing fantasies this afternoon I'm
going to describe a group of crusading
authoritarians who have recently gained
prominence on the college campus like
their predecessors they come armed with
a set of urgent reasons why they need to
abridge the basic freedoms of their
fellow students and they appear to be
their way I will describe these new
Crusaders I will try to explain where
they came from what motivates them and
why are they suddenly so influential why
are we suddenly hearing about the rape
culture and advocacy statistics that
used to be limited to the rarefied
confines of Gender Studies departments I
am also going to this will be the
briefest part of my talk suggest
solutions because I'm not entirely
confident what to do in the face of
hysteria but I'm going to describe these
new Crusaders to you as best I can
I am convinced that the millennial
generation is going to have to do what
previous generations have done they're
going to have to rise up and take back
their democratic freedoms who are these
authoritarian Crusaders I encountered
great numbers of them just a few weeks
ago when I was an invited speaker at
Georgetown a UCLA as well as Oberlin
College now I have been lecturing on
college campuses for more than 20 years
I have never seen anything like what's
going on today now I for those who don't
know I am a defender of a moderate
equality feminism I am a strong
proponent of women's liberation and
believe that the first and and most of
the second wave of feminism are just a
great American success story women for
the most part we're liberated and to
call contemporary women as is often the
case in today's Gender Studies
environment to call contemporary America
at patriarchy a male hegemony or a rape
culture it to me this is absurd this is
what I believe and I'm often criticized
by hardline grievance feminists who
believe that American women are a victim
class and no amount of evidence can
persuade them that they are wrong their
views if you're not to be falsifiable in
any conceivable universe the women are a
victim class my pleas for moderation
these are not appreciated on campus but
in the past the the grievance feminists
would either boycott my talks they would
sometimes organize counter events there
were usually some antics however many
cases they would just come to debate me
and that was great that was fine
sometimes we even go out for drinks and
and continue to argue and maybe even
become friends well this is not
happening today because today's campus
feminists the even before I arrived on
social media and throughout you know in
the campus newspaper there there are
frantic notices about my presence and
how I am a threat to their mental health
at both Oberlin and Georgetown they
organized safe spaces these are safe
rooms where students who might have been
panicked I am up by my arguments where
they could flee for comfort and sus
notes according to the Oberlin review
you can look a lot of it it's just worth
going looking at the articles before and
after my visit to Oberlin look at these
frenetic letters and and and op-eds
apparently 35 people went to the 35
people and a dog went to the to the safe
room while I was speaking now at both
cat both to all talk mainly about
Georgetown at Overland because it was
most theatrical at these campuses but
the rooms were packed there was a lot of
nervous energy it was somewhat nervous
because I saw they they were not happy
and they were angry Flyers everywhere
and trigger warnings about what they
were about to hear a typical flyer is at
Oberlin free speech does not mean hate
speech go home and take your eternal
eyes misogyny with you what bothered me
most is they on a wall they took the
names I had been invited to Oberlin by
the college libertarians and Republicans
not a large group but they invited me
and but they this
students the vigilantes I will call the
took their all of their names and had
posters you know that these are rape
apologists and singled them out I saw
they were very upset and there was a lot
of yelling and hooting during my talk
but for me the very worst moment at
Overland was when this kindly philosophy
professors have stood up and just urged
the crowd to calm down be civil and he
was heckled and screamed at and then
somebody just said sit down in the in
most a uncivilized way very rude way it
was a mob and here was a humane
individual just asking for courtesy this
is how he was treated at Oberlin College
and I'm quite certain that if these
people ever came to power they would
certainly have banned me from campus
probably for life and for good reason
from their point of view but if my
presence made the students feel unsafe
and endangered the school administration
came to a different conclusion and at
both Georgetown at Overland they
assigned a police escorts and after my
lecture at Overland to nerves police
women escorted me from the from the
podium looking around I I was not afraid
I mean a gender activists are don't have
a record of violence it's I wasn't as
scared but they were I think it was the
postings on Facebook it seemed a bit
worrisome for them and but I was put in
a police car
with some students and we were taken off
campus and deposited at a restaurant
where we we had dinner well it's easy to
laugh at all of this the melodrama the
psychobabble the self involvement is
alarming but let me be clear about a few
things before I continue about the
trigger warnings and the traumatized
students and so forth I am sure that
there are young women and men at Oberlin
at Georgetown probably on every campus
in the country there are some students
who have experienced trauma and they do
need to be
taken care of and I hope that our
colleges have psychological services to
to help them but there is no evidence
that this is more than a tiny minority
of students and it's unlikely that a
visiting scholar with dissenting views
on feminism is going to trigger PTSD now
I think that this movement is not really
about protecting vulnerable students I
think that it's just a new way to assert
power and control over others it's a way
of asserting your your cause without
having to bother with evidence and
argument you've just shamed people
intimidate them silenced them and you do
it with psychodrama now I'll add one
other comment I have never denied the
reality of campus sexual assault I think
it's a horrific crime it happens but I
have questioned exaggerated statistics
and by the way I wasn't at Oberlin or
Georgetown or any of these campuses I
wasn't there to talk about sexual
assault but the students found out that
I had said some politically incorrect
things what were these harmful and
dangerous thoughts of mine well I do
contest exaggerated statistics because I
don't think they help victims quite the
contrary
it's because I take the crime of assault
so seriously that I think we need
serious research we need sober
statistics and there's just no good
evidence that liberal enclaves like
Oberlin or swathmore or Georgetown or
Wesleyan that these are rape cultures
now Overland is the most extreme but
what I saw there is happening on
campuses everywhere and the more elite
and expensive the school the more likely
it is a hotbed of trigger warnings safe
spaces microaggression defence
initiatives and mob justice let me
briefly explain what some of these
phenomena are phenomena are should they
be new to you trigger warnings developed
in the feminist blogosphere
and they typically appeared at the
beginning of articles on websites where
people got together to discuss their
some trauma they may have had and so
they would say warning we were going to
talk about assault to ruin to talk about
eating disorders or we're going to talk
about what you know suicide but these
promptly moved from the blogs to
newspapers to the classroom and
professors at schools like Oberlin and
Rutgers UCSB Columbia they have been
urged now to place trigger warnings on
their class syllabi to warn students if
you're going to be this was it I think
Rutgers and at UCSB professors were told
if you were signing books like The Great
Gatsby or Huckleberry Finn things fall
apart place trigger warnings on the
reading list because they have content
that could trigger PTSD or panic
students lend up running from the room
in a state of anxiety a collapse and
collapsing at all sorts of various
warnings about what would happen student
leaders at Columbia just a few weeks ago
here we shock their professors and by
the way the liberal professors are
terrified they don't know what to do
they're not used to challenging the
politically correct left on the other
hand they know this is wrong and they're
scared they're now writing about it and
that Oberland some of the professor's
told me that they were actually scared
because they could say something and
make a student uncomfortable and end up
as one wrote in an anonymous blog I
could see my office suddenly being
occupied by frantic students carrying
mattresses or you know some trigger it
would trigger a a Twitter mob to demand
my head on a platter at Columbia which
they have a tradition in teaching the
great books well apparently the great
books are just full of materials that
can be triggering and professors were
warned to be careful in assigning them
to warn students and here's the quote
but these books could marginalize
student identities in the classroom at a
recent feminist conference in London
Deas who were all female student female
student leaders from colleges around the
country including Oxford and Cambridge
they warned the members of the audience
to please refrain from clapping because
as the conferees explained clapping can
trigger anxiety
perhaps panic in speakers and
participants in everybody
instead the audience was urged to
express approval by something called
feminist jazz hands so when you like
what the readers say this is madness now
for the record trigger warnings have no
basis in Psychological fact a scientific
fact they just they developed out of
feminist theory
Richard McNally is a Harvard
psychologist and an expert on anxiety
disorders and he recently published a
review of the relevant research and he
determined that if anything trigger
warnings are actually harmful and I
won't go into details but one of if a
student genuinely has PTSD the worst
thing you can do is to allow the trauma
two to define their lives and to
encroach but what you do is you
gradually expose them to triggering
events but of course we never know what
will trigger a traumatic reaction so all
of this is absurd and and not based on
anything other than a kind of bitter
ideology trigger warnings have created a
hostile environment for critical
thinking and free expression and as I
said the professor's are now worried
they're you know having suddenly died
I'm thinking I don't I don't know in
philosophy and teaching introduction to
metaphysics I don't know or a logical
analysis I try to think I guess there
are no occasions for trigger warnings
there but you can't be sure in addition
to the trigger warnings today's campus
feminists are committed to creating safe
spaces for one another so when Brown
University hosted a debate on they had a
debate on statistics about sexual
assault and one person was defending the
idea that twenty percent of college
women are victims and another person was
there
libertarian feminist Wendy McElroy and
she was questioning those statistics
well this created and ammonium and they
set up a room and again they were they
were accused of invalidating experience
apparently someone invalidates her
experience it's traumatizing so the safe
room came equipped this was described in
the New York Times in an article by
Judith Chu Lovitz the safe room came
equipped with cookies coloring books
bubbles play-doh calming music pillows
and blankets in a video of frolicking
puppies I read this and think this is
what the women's liberation has come to
boy anyway I host a weekly Internet a
video program called the factual
feminist
and I spend no more than five minutes
correcting a feminist myth of the week
or a feminist mistake or a fallacy and
it's been quite successful some of them
have had more than a half million views
so I'm educating someone or triggering a
lot of people I'm not sure but gender
activists at Oberlin and Georgetown and
UCLA and even Yale where I spoke they
didn't act out and Yale will be we'll
talk about that later but at Georgetown
and Oberlin they consider by Corrections
of their cherished fantasies to be a
form of trauma inducing hate speech and
that's why the campus visits of a sort
of bookish think tank number cruncher
cruncher now necessitates trigger
warnings and and warnings from the
rooftops and safe spaces for emotionally
endangered students now today's campus
activists are on constant alert for
micro aggressions committed by others
now what is a micro aggression these are
unintended comments or actions that
convey your ignorance hostility or
dismissal towards individuals belonging
to a marginalized group and on campus
and on the Internet you can be called
out for being micro aggressive
in some cases there's some legitimacy
some people do need to be reminded not
to be insensitive or you know lacking in
tact and I've seen many occasions where
I wanted to correct someone from a
something they said but I refrained well
they don't refrain they call them out
for as microaggressions but here's the
thing they're not just correcting solice
isms or you know people that are just
being rude or something you can be
called out for being for criticizing
feminism that's micro aggressive or for
suggesting that there might be
differences on average between men and
women differences between major
microaggression and of course all jokes
are out of bounds any joke about sex and
gender my god forget it
humor is not a strong point of grievance
feminism now I'm not going to spend a
lot of time explaining why all of this
is worrisome just three quick
observations since the time of Socrates
education has been synonymous with
debate inquiry challenge if the
universities replace the ideal of
rigorous and free intellectual inquiry
with safety they will have lost their
reason for being second all of this is
massively embarrassing to women to
feminism this safe space microaggression
trigger warning movement conveys the
idea that women are like wounded little
wounded birds who can't cope with life
it's regressive it's the opposite of
what a women's movement should be it's
the opposite of women's empowerment it's
it's fainting couch feminism third and
finally it's passive-aggressive it is a
bold assertion of power in the name of
vulnerability where did this come from
and what do they want well why are we
certainly hearing so much about it well
first I'll tell you where it came from
and then why now grievance feminism it's
been here for a long time and so have I
and I've been watching it since the
1980s I remember in the summer of 1985 a
philosophy professor at this
City University of New York Virginia
held she announced in the premier
Journal of philosophy at the time maybe
it's not now but at the time it was
hearts to publish in that journal she
announced that feminist theorists had
initiated a revolution an intellectual
revolution comparable and these are her
words comparable to those of Copernicus
Darwin and Freud indeed Center said held
quote some feminists think the latest
revolution will be even more profound
now what was it what did they discover
they discovered as she explained the sex
gender system a pervasive system whereby
men oppress women and she wrote this now
that the sex gender system has become
visible to us we see it everywhere now
my problem from the beginning is that I
just didn't see it everywhere but they
were like the Dutch naturalist van Lowe
and hooked looking through a microscope
and suddenly seeing this predatory
jungle well they were looking at society
through the prism of this some twisted
theory of oppression and they saw
oppression they saw women's
subordination everywhere
well they believed that every human
achievement bears the impressive
patriarchy literature philosophy science
music language it's not enough to reform
a few laws they dismiss liberal
feminists like me because they said oh
she just wants to perform a few laws or
change a few customs that won't do the
entire system must be taken down it must
be dismantled
you can't just they like to say this
this makes them laugh you say you can't
just add women and stir you must you
know radically we need a gender
revolution now I used to call this
gender feminism because they believe in
the sex gender system and now I call it
grievance feminism it grew out of it
just does not come out of the European
enlightenment this is not about human
about rationality and dignity and
liberty as this movement developed out
of the radical politics of the 60s as
well as the philosophy of karma
marks in his modern-day heirs Herbert
Marcuse a Franz fanon michel foucault
one prominent grievance feminist defined
a sex gender system this way she said
quote it is that complex system whereby
bisexual infants are transformed into
male and female gender personalities the
one destined to command the other to
obey I remember reading that definition
to my husband and he said which one
commands and which obey has been to
never know now it's easy to see why some
young women find this enthralling and
grievance feminism is exciting it
conspiracy theories have their
attractions and this particular paranoid
view of the world it offers them a
chance to be gender warriors in a battle
for liberation out mainstream moderate
equity feminism that can't compete with
grievance feminism when it comes to
excitement and comradery fervor
political activism the quest for power I
don't offer that like it I can't you
can't compete with if you have young
women who are and young people sometimes
do get carried away but pick up a gender
studies textbook or visit a Women's
Center or look at the syllabus of a
typical feminist theory class and you're
likely to find it elaborate theories
about the inner workings of the these
are the words of billhooks the
imperialist capitalist patriarchal
society today the fashion is
intersectional feminism and according to
this theory most of us are oppressed
under the imperialist capitalist
patriarchy that's a given but in all
kinds of different ways into different
degrees depending on your race your
class your ethnicity your sexual
orientation your age your body size your
blood type and maybe not blood type but
what would that be this approach might
have been an improvement over other
schools of feminism that tended to view
women as a monolithic group and men as a
model of the group you know at least
they were starting to look at
but it's turned out that it's it's
equally removed from reality and even
more bizarre in its way and it's not new
I saw intersectional feminism I saw it
in the beginning I saw where it was born
in 1992 I attended a conference of the
National Women's Studies Association and
because I was writing a paper about what
was going on in women's studies and they
weren't that happy that I was there
because I'd already written something
somewhat critical so there was all sorts
of caucusing about what to do about her
and I came with my sister in the
biological sense of the word my sister
Louise went with me and she's a
psychologist just to watch this
conference in Austin Texas and the theme
of the conference was anger grievance
and healing and participants we
immediately were told to break down into
our various grievance categories
according to your anger and healing
needs so you had groups like Jewish
women Jewish lesbians Asian American
women asian-american lesbians African
American women has been old women
disabled women fat women women whose
sexuality is in transition none of these
groups prove stable even at our
conference they started subdividing a
mad process of mitosis a kind of
victimology spinning out of control that
day the very first day a group of very
bitter women separated from all the
other group and demanded that they have
their own forum and these were women
with allergies they it's not funny
that's marginalizing they issued a set
of demands about it next year we demand
that no one wear clothes that have been
dry-cleaned or hairspray or other
irritants to the conference this here's
the thing the spirit of that my sister
was found it clinically fascinating as I
said she says they seem to be borderline
personalities or the spirit of that
conference is the spirit of today's
intersexual feminism intersectional
feminism the spirit of that conference
is alive and the trigger warnings the
safes
basse the microaggression monitors now i
want to say one thing in case there be
any confusion there are some serious
scholars in women's studies many
departments include a fair number of
solid non-ideological scholars who offer
straightforward courses in women's
history in women and literature I once I
recently wrote a book called freedom
feminism where I discussed the kind of
lost continent of conservative and
libertarian feminists who aren't part of
the feminist pantheon they're not
celebrated in Women's History Month that
they were there they're fascinating
they're wonderful and I depended on
these wonderful scholars mostly at UCLA
in women's studies women's historians
that have written so beautifully and G
and just eloquently about 18th century
proto-feminist
the blue stockings and various groups
who were somewhat conservative but who
changed the world in very positive ways
as I said left out of the feminist Canon
but thank you women studies scholars at
UCLA and it Brandeis and other places
that they were so helpful to me so I'm
not don't I don't want everyone to walk
to think Women's Studies is out of
control but here's the problem the
grievance collectors are there in most
of the departments and they set the tone
and they set the agenda and over the
years I have looked carefully at
grievance feminist claims about
everything about women and violence
women and eating disorders pay equity
women in education and what I have found
is it in most not all but most the
victim statistics are just wrong they're
misleading they're confused they're at
some are outright false what I'm saying
is that if you take a typical women
Studies class or an intro feminist
theory 101 typically you will encounter
a set of completely a baseless
statistics relentless a flow of Miss MS
information now
some people criticize me for talking
about feminist misinformation mistakes
they say why pick on feminists all books
have mistakes all groups exaggerate my
complaint with the grievant
feminist research is not so much that
the authors make mistakes it's that the
mistakes are impervious to criticism
they are impervious to they are beyond
the reach of rational analysis they do
not get corrected and I know this I had
a very bitter exchange with a feminist
scholar from UCLA who wrote the leading
text I think it's called a family it's a
domestic violence law it's full of
mistakes outrageous historical howlers
and it went into the third edition with
all the mistakes right there even though
I had told her and given her the sources
because in this if you are a
card-carrying grievance feminist you
automatically dismiss a critic as a
crank there has to be an agenda there
anyone that would question a feminist
victim statistic is by definition
disqualified as a critic networks will
no reasonable people can debate these
statistics about women and violence
women and with the pay gap women and
self-esteem literally women and so forth
all of that can be debated in these
classes they're not interested in debate
they can be counted on to ignore studies
that show low rates of victimization no
matter how rigorous they may be no
matter how fair-minded and they can be
counted on to report on studies that
show high levels of victimization no
matter how dubious or how questionable
the source so what I and other critics
have found is not Dutchess some mistakes
in the women's studies in the Gender
Studies Canon we have found a body of
egregiously false information but this
information has consequences as a
regular campus lecturer I routinely even
before the trigger Warners I routinely
encountered young women mostly young
women sometimes young men who have
imbibed this grievance propaganda and
their genuine love generally they're
kind of intelligent sensitive socially
concerned young people but they have
come to regard this grim feminist
worldview is incontrovertible truth and
most seem to be unaware that there is a
reasonable
empirically-based argument arguments
contrary to what they believe now this
is the opposite of what a university
should be if you go back and read John
Stuart Mill on Liberty
he didn't merely talk about the need for
freedom of expression he talked about
intellectual freedom in the deepest
sense and he warned that ideas have to
be freely and openly debated because if
they are not they become dead dogmas and
he insisted that an intellectually free
person had the right and the
responsibility to put himself in the
mental position of those who think
differently and he added that dissident
ideas are it's best if you are you
encounter them from someone who actually
believes them and someone who can
present them in their most plausible and
persuasive form so Mill was the great it
was part of our heritage of Liberty to
have centers of Education and learning
where ideas and dissident ideas freely
and openly debated in too many
universities today students they never I
don't want say never but probably never
hear arguments from libertarians are
conservatives even sometimes moderate
liberal ideas in women's studies
Department are looked down upon found
upon and so and this is all this is in
many departments of the universe and
universities but doubly true in gender
studies grievance feminism has tenure it
has a monopoly on the discourse on women
in our university and it's dead dogmas
are taken seriously now history is one
long lesson in the dangers of combining
moral fervor and misinformation if you
have good information and you have moral
energy we get the civil rights movement
you get human progress
but what if you have bad information
propaganda that toxic combination breeds
dell'utri anatta sysm and on our campus
and in some of our women's groups that's
what we have intolerance of dissent
vigilantism shouting down speakers and
all of this supported by this foundation
of propaganda a fall statistics but now
I want to turn the corner and address
the question of why are why did all this
suddenly become so newsworthy because as
I said this has been going on on
campuses since the 80s maybe even the
70s in some places now the trigger
warnings are new but conspiracy theories
about the patriarchy the sex gender
system even the all-encompassing rape
culture that that is flourished in the
Academy for decades but until recently
it remained there what brought it into
the mainstream why are we suddenly
hearing about the rape culture why how
did it get into the public square
now of course social media has played a
part in the proliferation of feminist
blogs and websites and but I don't
believe we would be where we are today I
don't believe that what happened to me
at Oberlin Georgetown and other places
Emily that would happen if it were not
for a specific event in 2010 that year a
left-leaning organization called the
Center for Public Integrity they teamed
up with reporters at National Public
Radio and they produced a massive study
describing a hidden rape and sexual
harassment culture on campus they in
there the director at the Center for
Public Integrity described it as a
nightmare
what's happening to our daughters now as
I have said campus sexual assault
harassment these are genuine problems
but this report made it seem as if our
colleges were these these catastrophic
centers of male predation and cruelty
and female helplessness and suffering
not only that this report which had you
know
the cachet of coming from this respected
Center for Public Integrity and NPR I
mean Joseph Shapiro on Morning Edition
you listen to him in his voice that he
was reporting these findings and it
sounds of course it has to be true he
wouldn't be reporting it it wasn't true
this report was the worst kind of
advocacy research it was full of of
unfounded statistics manipulative
anecdotes I have no time to go into more
detail about it I'll just say that
before the Rolling Stone made headlines
with its media hoaxes about the UVA
fraternity gang rape NPR and the Center
for Public Media they carried out a far
more consequential hoax hoax isn't quite
the right word it was a reckless and
irresponsible case of advocacy
journalism but here's here's why it it
was so consequential the NPR Public
Integrity team they took their findings
to oh by the way in this study they not
only uncovered this epidemic of rape and
predation but they said campus officials
are doing nothing and the federal
government is doing nothing
they're revitalizing the women so this
was an indictment of everybody from NPR
the Center for Public Integrity so NPR
and the report they went directly to the
Department of Education and they
confronted the Assistant Secretary of
Education russlynn ali with evidence of
massive malfeasance and secretary ali
promised action I mean she believed the
report she was already going to make
some changes but it it's very well
documented I wrote this in an article in
the in The Daily Beast if anyone wants
details but forget that but the
education Russell Ali promised them I'm
going to do something about it she was
she was motivated now the educational
equity law title 9 protects students
against gender discrimination but as the
report said what could be more
discriminatory then a hostile climate
created
by sexual violence so secretary Olli
leading the office for civil rights this
is the agency responsible for enforcing
title 9 on April 4th 2011 she sent out a
now-famous Dear Colleague letter at
least famous among college officials and
students and those of us who worried
about basic rights on campus she sent
out this letter telling them they were
telling the officials look we've got a
plague of abuse on campus and she told
universities you've got to have trials
you've got to you know convict people
under the lowest standard of proof it's
called preponderance of evidence there
was not a single word about civil
liberties there wasn't a word about
freedom of expression and initially they
defined harassment I mean even if
someone could overhear something that
they found uncomfortable with sexual
content these could be a basis for a
charge now the as I said there wasn't a
word about civil rights and he basic
freedom of expression and so forth NPR
and the Center for Public Integrity
along with the office of civil rights
they gave credit credibility and
legitimacy to the conspiratorial stage
space trigger warnings people they
empowered them because right after that
these young women were turning up
everywhere and are suddenly everybody
wanted to write about it because with it
with the as I said that cachet of an in
the imprimatur of NPR in the Center for
Public Integrity it had to be true so
these young women read about it they had
they had big they could make a federal
case out of what they learned in their
gender studies class and schools had to
worry never to dismiss their their
complaints no matter how baseless are
absurd because they could face a federal
investigation so the term rape culture
which as I said was previously limited
to gender Theory seminars
entered the national lexicon at and that
was largely because of that Dear
Colleague letter before long otherwise
sensible people came to believe that
Yale swathmore University of Michigan
but these were among the most dangerous
places on earth for women colleges
rushed to meet the new requirements
dozens of falsely accused of apparently
falsely accused young men were subjected
to kangaroo court proceedings and
expelled from college I forget the
latest number I think the sixty maybe
more lawsuits young men that were risen
- it takes a lot to sue your school your
suing their school for this travesty of
these hearings by 2014 and 15 the panic
produced outbursts of extreme zealot
Rhee young women you know we had this
young woman carrying her mattress around
at Columbia University she was permitted
to do that to humiliate and it was a
kind of vigilante action against a young
man who had been found not guilty in by
campus tribunals using the lowest
standard of proof on college campuses
students were triggered suddenly by
songs by works of art at Wellesley
College somebody put a statue of a sort
of frumpy guy in the quad and he was
just wearing I don't know boxer shorts
or something in the girls were falling
apart yeah not all of them but a number
of them wanted it removed because they
were triggered it wasn't a great work of
art oh my aesthetics were triggered but
but how annoying for them to to carry on
this way and and but then hello and what
was much worse than the songs in the
statue works of our trigger warnings and
works of literature you can go on
YouTube I don't recommend you do it
because it's uh it's dismaying and
depressing but you can find examples of
speakers on campus and far worse than
what happened to me I was at least
allowed to speak people were hooting and
hollering and carrying on but I was
allowed to speak there are now campuses
where a speaker like me the the gender
lawyers come and they chant and they get
louder and louder until you you can't
you have to cancel the event this is
going on this is even the Nation
magazine is a little worried about
Xavier behaving like Little Red Guards
and when the nation is saying that we
have a problem I think the nation was
talking about another group of fanatics
on on Twitter but this is about the
Academy
now when Rolling Stone published its
apocryphal article about a sadistic and
premeditated fraternity gang rape at the
University of Virginia many who should
have known better took it seriously when
I read it I immediately saw that it was
a kind of Gothic fantasy based on these
twisted theories and false statistics
that had been it been percolating along
for years this was the world view of
gender feminism but now it was in
Rolling Stone and PN and the New York
Times believed it and a lot of people
did until it fell apart in a matter of
days it was nurtured by poorly designed
studies by panic and of course political
figures got into the fray
senator Gillibrand Claire McCaskill
organ and bringing in these young women
to to Congress and these young women
they do have the spirit it was almost as
if that crazy conference I attended in
1992 with my sister with these these
injured groups with their healing
circles and carrying on it and I think
these might be their daughters or their
their heirs they are there now and
they're in one of them the mattress girl
was invited by Senator Gillibrand to the
State of the Union she didn't bring her
mattress but anyway
title nine was passed in order to give
women equal educational opportunities
but thanks to this April 11th your
colleague letter brought to us by NPR
and the Center for Public Integrity it
has been interpreted to mean the schools
have to make sure that they're safe they
provide a safe place for even the most
hypersensitive like neuro static person
there is then a person among them they
have to feel safe and comfortable well
before considering what could be done to
stem the tide of gender fanaticism on
campus
I'm just going to quickly consider an
argument against some of what I've been
saying which I heard many times some
people will say to me look I admit some
of this is crazy I don't like the
trigger warnings and the safe spaces
it's a bit silly but there is too much
sexual violence on campus
it needed a correction yeah they're
going a little overboard but rape and
harassment or so are so terrible maybe
we need to go over but maybe we need
extreme solutions extreme direct action
to solve an extreme problem so they're
drawing attention to a real problem
maybe they're not doing it in the right
way but it's it's in the direction of
progress here is why that argument is
completely wrong it is precisely because
campus sexual assault is a genuine
problem that people should avoid antics
hyperbole hysteria these reactions get
in the way of solutions hysteria which I
personally witnessed at Oberlin and
Georgetown these breed chaos confusion
mob justice they claim innocent victims
they undermine social trust they
distract attention from genuine cases of
abuse and remember the hysteria is not
only distracting us from finding
effective solutions to campus assault
it's turning our campuses into hostile
environments for freedom and for
education well what are we going to do
to stop it
how can we stop a contagion of it to me
it seems like hysteria when I was at a
Overland and talking to some of the
students is strong but I think
sustainable I felt I was dealing with
members of a cult well what we do to
deprogram them I'm not sure that I am
NOT as a philosopher I have no training
and I did look up a psychiatric
literature on contagions and hysteria
and solutions and and studied the Salem
witch trials rather carefully
what are we going to do to stop this
this movement grievance feminism I'm
going to race through these because I
want to open this up for discussion so
very quickly and then I will subside
first thing I think we all have to do
and anyway we can't make the case for
freedom I said in the beginning every
generation has the challenge and we're
here especially the Millennials I speak
on a lot of campuses and I try to
directly tell these students you don't
want to be the generation where freedom
went to die that that should not be your
legacy now as a philosophy professor
it's perhaps I'm naive but I have great
faith in the power of rational discourse
I have changed my views when confronted
with counter evidence and and by the way
whenever I go to the campuses I tell
them I know about confirmation bias we
all have a tendency to embrace anything
that reinforces what we already believe
and we have a built-in tendency to
dismiss and not take seriously just
count anything that undermines our
beliefs and I try span you Islita fight
that I see it in myself I try to fight
it but these are the this is about being
rational about being reasonable and I
have faith in that there was a very wise
person who once said the voice of reason
is small but it's persistent so reason
can prevail over madness but only if
reasonable people speak up so today at
least on the campus the forces of
unreason are more organized and they're
more vocal so reason needs a lobby
I urge all of you to become part of it
in any way you can political reform we
are going to need to see political and
legal challenges to those changes made
in title 9 in on April 4th 2011 the
collet you will have a lot it you would
have a lot of support from colleges
because it's thrown them into into
complete chaos and havoc and costing a
fortune to do everything that this
letter says they have to do now be
prepared if you challenge this
politically
be prepared for us frenzied reaction
from the safe spacers and a lot of the
media will take their side on the other
hand there are growing number of
responsible journalists who know
something has gone badly wrong on the
campus and as I said even the Nation
magazine is worried about the safe
spacers I don't think anybody is
comfortable with the trigger Warner's
except the trigger Warner's number three
more lawsuits students and professors
whose rights to free expression and due
process have been compromised need to
turn to the courts and this is happening
there's a group called the foundation
for individual rights in education fire
I think I'm on the board so full
disclosure but it's a nonprofit that is
kind of an ACLU for academic freedom and
it has conservatives and liberals and
it's it's nonpartisan but it's pro
freedom and it's awesome and anytime a
school tries to have a speech code or do
something crazy to abridge students
basic rights they have lawyers who write
very threatening letters that intimidate
we've got legal Legally threatening huh
personally fit and they they were now
helping students to sue and I mentioned
lawsuits because as it's well known that
the Salem witch trials they began to
wind down when a wealthy and influential
people started to be accused and there's
a one historical account they were they
gentleman from Boston who was accused
rather late in the in the in the frenzy
and he went directly to court and sued
his accusers for slander for a lot of
money and according to some historical
accounts that was decisive in stopping
the hysteria
people didn't realize you could be you
could have to face consequences for this
they should know there will be
consequences if these slander people
finally humor fainting couch safeSpace
grievance feminism is just an open
invitation for satire and parody
so an humor can be a very potent weapon
someone recently placed a song parody
about my visit to Oberlin College they
placed it on YouTube
it's entitled please don't put us in the
real world and it's allegedly sung by
the Oberlin College Choir I don't think
it is but they've denied it to them I'm
sure it's something someone's I don't
know they I'm surprised I haven't taken
credit for it because it's had found a
hundred thousands of I don't know
seventy eighty ninety thousand views
people like it it's being written about
but no one but I don't know who wrote it
but it's very clever please don't put me
in the real world I think that song has
had more publicity than they might that
certainly my lecture so it's a good way
to draw attention to your cause feminist
propaganda irresponsible journalism
politicians willing to bend the law to
address a phantom catastrophe what a
mess and what a hostile environment for
learning for happiness at this very
moment campus officials across the
country are quietly amending the US
Constitution and freedom of expression
is being replaced by the right not to be
made uncomfortable due process is being
treated as a barrier to justice rather
than the essence of justice armies of
gender apparatchik SAR monitoring and
policing speech ideas humor even
clapping Orwell's George Orwell from
1984 if you remember the Junior anti-sex
League they've set up shop right in our
midst so today's Millennials are going
to have to decide are they going to be
the generation that stands by helplessly
or even applauds as their basic freedoms
are stripped away my guess is that the
Millennials like generations before them
will eventually rally and defend their
liberties I already see signs of
resistance I just hope it comes sooner
rather than later and it grows quickly
because the victim industrial complex is
tightening its grip our our institutions
of higher learning have to be open and
free places of intellectual diversity
and challenge today they are not they
have been called islands of repression
in a sea of freedom well it's
time to liberate the islands thank you
and both clapping and jazz hands are
welcome too scared to let thinkers like
which is your alma mater Sean so
professor where our scholars supposed to
go if their administrators are too
scared of speakers like you coming to
debate and discuss issues that make
others uncomfortable on the ivory towers
and well you return to a campus like
Georgetown if you're treated like that
oh well I would I would because I don't
like bullies and this is I mean I'm not
really I mean if I were really scared to
death I probably wouldn't I'm not afraid
and it's an unpleasant experience
somewhat it's also kind of interesting
so I recommend it and you have to do it
and I want more I really am disappointed
in college faculty because they have
tenure and they're still scared it's so
strange because I thought the purpose of
tenure was that you were liberated and
to speak your mind and yet they don't do
it so what can we do well I think we
have to keep doing what we're doing we
have a it's interesting because as I
grew up very liberal and I'm still think
of myself as a kind of hippie protestor
flower child but this put me on the side
of conservatives on so many issues
because it's conservatives and
libertarians who are defending freedom
defending humor defending fun even sex
what happened it all switched and it was
there was a time all the comedian's you
know that the right-wing I don't know
some right-wing forces didn't want you
know wanted to the police mayor's they
wanted to arrest George Carlin or Lenny
Bruce or something no it's conservatives
defending the commedia saw a wonderful
article but it was Molly Hemingway in
the Federalists saying conservatives and
libertarians we have to form humor
speakeasies you know not places where
you go to drink the places where you can
go to laugh you
tell jokes you can be a dissident you
can try out you know so I think we just
have to have fun and although it's some
level I think it's probably this is
going to require a civil war on the left
and I don't know if the leftists have
the heart to fight it because the fear
of looking a liberal the fear of looking
like christina hoff sommers too many
feminists they don't want that they
can't do it so that's why I'm a lot
about the students I think maybe the
students have to push it they need their
own free speech movement and push their
elders because the elders are timid I
mean for years have we thought this was
going to be easy when we fought the
first culture war we had and then we had
journalists on our side the New York
Times was on our side and we won the
arguments that they won the assistant
professorship quietly behind the scene
and now they're there and now a whole
generation have been educated by them
and they're out there with these ideas
so do anything you can to provide
exposure to new ideas and of course we
have the Internet so we can't complain
about not having venues but again people
tend to read just what's reinforces
their beliefs to break that down well
thank you so much two quick questions
but first I just want to say thank you
Christina for going into these hot beds
of debate and if it is debate but it
takes a lot personally so thank you for
being a warrior for truth I would say
but my questions are did you see
anything as you move around these
environments about Islam and how Islam
treats women and secondly how do you
connect this with the mob tactics of
other places that were watching as
divisiveness comes up starting with
Wisconsin and what happened right these
tactics of claiming that you are going
to be panicked and triggered they're
being used by other groups so I think
recently the University of Michigan they
wanted to show a film what was the name
of the film with American sniper and
there was a brouhaha about that and
how was it would make the certain Muslim
students feel uncomfortable and so forth
so of course that's going on and just
terrible conference in I face because
some of these people are willing I've
seen speaker I think it was a police
chief from New York who was practically
I don't even know he was talking about
oh I think it was I forget where he was
but he was on a college campus and he
was simply trying to talk about his
experiences as a police chief in New
York City and uh protesters came and he
was not allowed to speak he had to just
leave the room and so this this is this
is going on and you can't understand why
does the college administration why do
they permit it and why aren't the aware
of their consequences for doing
something that's such a threat the very
purpose of the institution so yes it's
going on in other areas and I think
there are a lot of women on campus and a
lot of people that sort of go along with
this movement so it may be the most
forceful the most the one you hear about
all the time and there are a lot of
young men who are subject to their
various protocols and their their
workshops and corrections and so young
men now are presumed guilty the fact at
the moment they arrive on campus it's
almost as if there are proto rapists and
proto survivors and the proto rapist are
the boys and the survivors are because
in shocking and demeaning workshops and
seminars and and assemblies and
goings-on so that's that's hard to miss
if you're on campus the others probably
hard to miss depending on the size of
the campus and what's going on but then
you mentioned something else what was
the first party oh yes this is what I
found sad and will have any things I
find sad obviously about what's going on
but I'm so shocked at how narcissistic
this is on the campuses there's so much
there's so much going wrong in the world
there's so many problems that need
solution and let's suppose you are
committed to the emancipation of women
well I've been to several international
women's conferences
and I have met women from places like
Egypt and Yemen and even Iran and they
are there fighting for what we we won in
both first and second wave feminism and
there I have met women coming from
societies that have not not only have
they not had two major waves of feminism
as we have they have not had so much as
a ripple and they are they want to make
common cause with American women and we
did organize and liberate ourselves and
we are good they see us as inspiring why
are these young women at Oberlin College
and at Wellesley it is these elite there
it's all on their own in how I've been
injured and poor little me this is this
is a lost this is a disaster
because it's so so they're not they're
not there if you see what's happening
with women in Iran or what's happening
today in Egypt and Yemen
why aren't they interested in fact
they're more like if you bring it up
they're more likely to say that you're
violating some principle of
multiculturalism by being critical and
so there there are feminists who say
that it's just a part of the capitalist
patriarchal colonialist mentality to
feel that we have anything to impart to
other societies but I happen to believe
that there are universal ideals and I
have M BER one young woman from Cambo a
she was from I will call it Burma she
was from Burma and she had been in jail
for ten years because she'd taken out a
petition for democracy and she got out
and what does she do the next day she
started handing out petitions for
democracy she was the bravest person
I've ever had I'm aware of meeting and
then she said to the audience and this
was Westerners in New York she said
democracy isn't only for the West it's
for mankind that was her commitment this
was like a little you know Patrick Henry
that I was meeting from from from Burma
so and those are those are exciting
people these are morally there it's
electrifying why are
our students meeting her why aren't they
meeting and and agitating for liberty
and for education for freedom for for
women for everyone across the world and
so that's the price we're paying is we
have a generation that activism is
inward it's for me it's all part of the
me generation or I don't know if it's
the helicopter parenting the self-esteem
there are many many causes but I will
tell you that entitled generation
they're not all like that but the ones
that I on these universities that little
Enclave are entitled preoccupied
everything always you know went the way
you thought it should and if it didn't
it was a crisis they've carried that
into their college life and there they
seem to be blind to the needs of people
outside themselves
thank you very much
every senator is always a safe zone for
your discussions I just quickly bring
you to mind you of us they say the date
on your on your seat Gerald wiggler the
wonderful professor at University of
Dallas he's the really the expert on
Thomas More since be speaking on Thomas
one statesmanship Mike Lee is here on
June 11th that he's concerned about the
future of religious liberty in the
United States it's going to be speaking
about that topic and legislation on that
matter and professor Robert George of
Princeton University who holds the
Woodrow Wilson's chair in jurisprudence
Princeton University is speaking just
before the Supreme Court decisions about
the future of marriage and family here
on June 23rd thank you have a great day